que tanto impactan estos avances
reclamados por ucrania la operación
llevada a cabo por rusia
bueno demuestran que ha sido un fracaso
al menos en su objetivo principal que
había sido tratar de copar de invadir en
febrero a toda ucrania en pocos días eso
pues se vio ya desde los primeros meses
que era imposible y ahora a pesar de los
avances que moscú había logrado en el
lugar y en donges por ejemplo pues hay
esta contraofensiva
al norte norte y noreste de harkov que
ha logrado empujar a los rusos y parece
que los rusos se han agotado no tienen
digamos que la fuerza
digamos que el equipo la motivación la
moral para seguir adelante parece como
que se han empantanado así que es muy
relevante porque a ucrania con las
fuerzas occidentales la tecnología el
armamento que occidente le está dando y
su entrenamiento también cómo usar
adecuadamente ese equipo están logrando
empujar rusos y probablemente no se va a
quedar allí el objetivo de ucrania es
liberar todo su territorio incluyendo la
crimea aunque tome tiempo pero este esta
contraofensiva no sólo por hardcore pero
también los avances aunque lentos al sur
y por gerson está demostrando que rusia
ahora está en una fase de defensiva y
habrá que ver si logra recuperar la una
y la iniciativa pero da la impresión que
ahora la iniciativa la tiene ucrania
doctores e incluso expertos comentan que
en las tropas rusas estarían en
desventaja cuando se acerque el invierno
porque que nos pueden llegar para
acercar esto bueno la logística está muy
mal se han quejado ya tropas rusas de no
solamente que no les pagan falta de
alimentos falta también de uniformes o
sea de
equipo equipamiento vestimentas etcétera
de un informe camuflado
y bueno aparte ya de
combustible para los vehículos etcétera
hay digamos que no solamente hay una
derrota en el campo de batalla en cuanto
al combate se refiere hay una derrota
rusa en el campo logístico ya que su
logística para reaprovisionar y su
suplir a sus fuerzas deja mucho que
desear así que claro el invierno se va a
tornar muy difícil y si eso añadimos las
sanciones económicas de occidente que
están impactando la economía rusa y otra
cosa la oposición que ya se está
observando entre ciertos sectores
políticos como concejales de san
petersburgo de moscú que podría ser la
punta del témpano que realmente se está
incubando una oposición mucho más
profunda pero que no se ha manifestado
abiertamente contra vladimir putin y su
guerra precisamente sobre este tema
quería comentarle porque son políticos
locales los que piden al parlamento
estatal que presente acusaciones de
traición contra putin para destituirlo
de su cargo tiene futuro esta solicitud
bueno del momento da la impresión que
putin está firmemente en el poder por el
apoyo de los servicios de inteligencia
de la fsb servicio seguridad federal y
que podría estar también dominando a las
fuerzas armadas o sea que no habría
posibilidades aparentes de un golpe
contra putin en ese sentido y son tropas
procesos profesionales los generales que
no estarían al menos de momento- 12b en
pos de un alzamiento de un golpe pero no
se puede descartar si sigue digamos que
una guerra que el tiempo va en contra de
putin mientras más larga sea esta guerra
más va a sufrir su base de poder más va
a sufrir la economía rusa y más derrotas
probablemente va a recibir puede
intentar quizá la tarjeta la baraja de
armas nucleares tácticas podría ser
capaz pero eso implicará una reacción
por parte de la otan que para que como
mínimo ucrania tenga los medios
tecnológicos para derrotar
definitivamente a rusia y quizá a
bombardear la en su territorio